today we're having a very important
meeting with the man you can trust the
country finances the Chancellor of
Exchequer George Osborn chargers funds
used to touch questions but wait a
minute sucks with [ __ ] to sky needs to
find out about his life before politics
and how it unwind after a busy day in
Downing Street hello and welcome to the
first ever hot seat and exciting new
collaboration between sky and first news
the UK's national newspaper for young
people let's get started and first up is
Sam I am good at maths well I did mess
ailable so I have been tested at school
seven-time rate I've made it a rule in
life not to answer when you were a child
did you spend or save your pocket money
well I spent it much at the time but I
did save up for something called ask a
lectric seeeeee do using their MP set a
good example by shouting and calling
each other names in the House of Commons
well I take a slightly different view
from lots of people on this and I know
when you see it on television it can
look very rowdy and people are shouting
at each other and they're grown-ups is
there probably not as well behaved as
you are in your classes I'd much rather
have a House of Commons a farmer which
its lively and people feel passionately
about things then a really quiet place
we've had an overwhelming response from
both first news readers and sky Academy
students of all ages they've been
sending in loads of questions so we
thought we should let them get involved
here are some of the best selfie
questions how much money do you are a
year well I get paid 100 34,000 pounds
if the country was in debt and you
needed help sorting at that problem who
would you ask and why David Cameron we
work as a real team doesn't always
happen in politics huge beside Kendrick
Lamar
j cool oh gosh I gotta pass on that one
do I did a straw poll in the office that
only one hand went up come on you can
tell us Jonathan with rappers and the
birth up-and-coming I'm gonna go with
your judgment pharell Williams I love
his songs I think they're they're kind
of uplifting and they're kind of villain
what decision that you've made during
your time in government do you regret
most when you get into office that's
your best opportunity to take some
really big decisions if anything it's
like I wish we had done even more but
that's alright we're doing more now it's
been an interesting game it was great to
meet the Chancellor George gave some
great artists first bike to the hardest
question Mr Osborne was very friendly
and I bro we think is a great job maybe
one of us will be a politician